in a swamp on the edge of rio stands a
biologist consumed by the fight against
climate change and against a president
he says doesn't care
we have a strange president when the
issue is the environment
we're walking through mario moscatelli's
passion project this ecosystem is very
important
he is working to create the biggest
urban mangrove forest in brazil this is
one way to
fight
against
the the climate change it's very very
important these trees
this is a settling of the seedling yeah
seedling
he's planted three quarters of a square
mile so far and is keeping going
this is a new planting
but it is not straightforward the
disastrous habits of man are taking
their toll here
we have tires
television
domestic garbage
an unending tide of debris is just about
kept at bay by an unstable fence but it
is unremitting
and it is depressing
so this is
your nightmare yeah you're trying to
build
you're trying to build a new this is my
dream and here is nightmare
yes
mario says it all means too much of
their time here is spent doing this
rather than planting trees the cleanup
is never ending
what we're witnessing here is quite
incredible one man and his team battling
against pollution battling
against uh climate change but you can
see just what they're up against here
further in we walk towards what his
dream is all about be careful please
this is of course tiny stuff when
confronted with vast areas of rainforest
being destroyed as i speak
but these seedlings were planted last
year and many many more are planned by a
man so desperate to change things here
at least some hope is taking root right
now in mario's mangrove